hey guys what's up I'm Alana welcome to
my channel today we're going to be
talking about zero latency which is
basically a full motion via experience
that's set up in a space in Melbourne
over 450 square foot warehouse and it
effectively puts you in a zombie shooter
and lets you walk around in it zero
latency uses the oculus rift dk2 and
alienware pc that's in a little backpack
that you have to carry around with you a
replica gun that weighs 2.5 kilos and
has two buttons one to reload and one to
change weapons between your shotgun and
your rifle and both the headset and the
gun have these little ping-pong balls
that are kind of like the ends of the
PlayStation Move controllers that light
up so they can be seen by the 128
cameras that are in this big room it's
basically a big completely empty space
that as soon as you put on the oculus
rift is transformed into a zombie
shooter that you walk around in after I
questioned about this on Instagram and
Facebook a lot of people asked how they
deal with the walls
so basically when you're in the
simulator if you get close to a
real-world wall a wall will appear in
the game that's just kind of like giant
red thing that will just sort of you
know will notify you that but that's a
real wall because outside of that they
don't have all the walls shown in the
game it looks like the street goes
forever until you get to a point where
you're dangerously close to it and it
pops up and it's like by the way you
don't want to go here there's also a
warning for if you get too close to
another player someone else you're
playing with so that you don't run into
each other though you can also see each
other in the VR your mapped out as
military dudes now I am a giant VR
fanboy so keep that in mind when I'm
talking about
this I love via I love the oculus rift I
love the PlayStation vo when I tried it
I I'm just so excited about them coming
out I have loved every single video game
I've ever played and I can't imagine
there would be one that I would really
dislike because I just find the
experience so mercy that and so
incredible but take it with a grain of
salt when I tell you that this is
amazing you completely forget that
you're in an empty room you would have
no idea that there are 128 cameras
watching you or 14 computers running a
simulation for you as soon as you put on
an oculus rift you believe that you are
in this world that's infested with
zombies so we've established that the
hardware works and that it's just epic
so we should probably talk about the
actual game that you play and how that
works right the game that you are
playing it even feels me to say that
because you're walking you're not
holding a controller or keyboard mouse
you're actually walking around and
shooting it's tough physically but let's
call it a game just for the sake of it
it's a very basic zombie shooter that
has you walk from one point of a map to
another point there's a little green
marker that you have to go and stand in
and then it will lay below it another
point or a yellow marker will be an
objective like calling a lift if you get
a lift and then if you go to another
level
obviously you can't interact with
anything so you can't actually call the
lift you just have to stand in the
yellow marker to do an objective and to
be honest none of the objectives are
particularly interesting knowing the
environments very interesting it's all
just like the street with some zombies
and you know some cars broken down or
like an office building it's all really
really standard and the graphics are not
particularly good and it does have that
graininess that the oculus rift dk2
tends to suffer
so if it weren't a VR thing and it
didn't work so damn well with the AH it
would be like the worst game ever it's
not very good but you can dismiss all
that because of the way that you get to
interact with things having a zombie run
up at you when you're not expecting one
- and having to like actually just sort
of step back and shoot it is such a
surreal thing but my favorite thing
about even these boring environments the
way they used is if it's it's mapped out
really creatively you have a 450 square
meter space but you do about 700 meters
of walking in that experience so it'll
have you know an office room with desks
and chairs and and obstacles in your way
that I mean you could walk through them
they're not actually there I wanted to
but I just couldn't bring myself to do
it the idea of walking through a desk
was too weird to me I just couldn't
bring myself to walk through something
so basically what it does is just feed
you through environments and obviously
you're reusing the same parts of the
warehouse all the time but you don't
realize you are because the environments
are catered to this experience it really
does seem like they thought of
everything and zero latency is
definitely very functional but there are
outside of the bad graphics and the game
being boring if it won't be are there
are a few issues sometimes the virtual
gun will lean to the left or the right
and not quite aligned with the way that
you are holding the physical gun so it
will look like your gun is pointing in a
different direction to how you're
actually holding it which means you kind
of have to adjust for that that happened
to me a couple of times as well where my
character in VR was strafing but I was
walking straight so I sort of had to
start strafing to match that that is a
little bit annoying but it didn't happen
very often so I guess closing thoughts
on this would be that it's incredible
because VR is incredible and
the hardware that they have for this is
amazing but I think there is obvious
room for improvement and I expect that
this is going to get much much better as
VR develops and I guess as it's around
for longer I'm really interested to see
where they take it the different kind of
games that they might have you play or I
guess the different simulations that
you'll go through because this one in
itself was boring if it weren't for how
freaking amazing the fact that it
actually functions is I really like it
but that's it for me today you guys I'm
Alana thank you for watching I will see
you guys next time
oh my